your phone is cracked you found me
you need a new ipad you phone me you
need a new phone you phone me laptop
ipads whatever you want brothers and
sisters your phone
us not me because i don't do phone
repairs but if you come to phone ask
brothers and sisters
you can get this guy if you mention my
name and they are sponsors for this
amazing video
check it out inshallah don't go anywhere
not only does it encourage you to read
it tells you how many verses you've read
how many pages you read how long you've
been on it and best of all the hasanah
counter
download the qurani app now and have a
ramadan with allah subhanahu wa tala's
book like you've never had before
zeeshan have you ever wondered if the
general public the non-muslims
have you ever wondered if the general
public know what an actual woman's hijab
or a men's hijab is
no no really let's find out which one do
you think is the correct
hijab is it number one two or three the
headgear
so think about it and come to a decision
and let me know
two two okay is the correct form of
dress for the bottom is it a
b or c so i think about it
aye aye aye okay good which headgear do
you believe is the correct
form of hijab one two or three
three three three yeah okay which one do
you think is the correct
um garment to wear at the bottom a b or
c
a i think a yes b b
a yeah okay all right so for the head
gear which one do you think is the
correct
form of hijab to wear on the head is it
one two or three
three three okay all right and from the
bottom where is it a
b or c
yeah final answer yeah danielle what is
the correct form of headgear hijab
that a woman should wear one two or
three
two dude okay the bottom where for a
muslim woman is it
a b or c a a
a yeah yeah okay no problem as you know
muslim women wear the hijab
yeah which one is the correct one one
two or three all right i'll give you 10
seconds to think
yeah sorry yeah one two or three
three no i'd say it's free what are you
talking about
no because it's obviously a trick
question it's not it's not trick
it's not true which one do you think it
is yeah three foreign
okay so when it comes to the lower
garment is it a
b or c
a yeah okay one two or three think about
it let me know
three three yeah okay
the lower part of the dress a b or c
okay yeah hey hey yeah yeah
okay hijab for women is it one two or
three for muslim women
three three yeah okay so the bottom
where the dress
for the body a b or c a
okay and one two or three three three
three yeah yeah three okay you guys
muslim okay
all right the lower part of the uh
clothing which is the correct
a b or c okay
two or three i think it's two two okay
i've got two two two
i'll be the trick question but a in it
yeah
think about it both of you guys and let
me know
three three three okay is it a b
or c for a muslim woman c c
okay you said eight one two or three
three oh that was first one okay a b
or c four i think muslims should wear
what they want to wear
if they want to be covered up in jeans
why not they just want to be covered up
that's their interest
one two or three three i think no
uh maybe two maybe two no actually
because you can see the head
in the fringe okay well you said
something interesting what did you say
because you can see the head i said you
can see the hair yeah
okay all right interesting okay so when
it comes to the bottle
very beautiful um i would say the third
one looks
okay no problem i would say a as well
correct
headgear a woman should be wearing a
muslin woman is it one three is it two
or three
three yeah yes okay that was first okay
now when it comes to the lower
garment a b or c a
okay can i ask why three but not one and
two for the top
just just a comment is there anything
it's because they've got hair showing
they're they're kind of christmas
yeah yeah yeah what about the bottom one
why did you pick a
but not b or c is it the same thing or
is there a specific reason it could be b
it's not def it's definitely not c why
not c
that's westernized okay
why a i think she's more covered up you
can't really see the shape of her
okay so so you believe that they
shouldn't the shape should not be seen
well not
that they should no no no no no no as a
muslim that they believe okay i feel
like that would be the correct way yeah
okay all right any reason why three but
not one or two job
so one and two is not hijab i don't know
okay all right okay can i ask you why
you pick three but not one and two
um because they have to cover their hair
uh most of as much
they have to be modest and cover their
hair okay all right when it comes to
a b or c you pick a why not b or c um
because
it shouldn't be i don't think their
clothes should be fitting like to show
their figure it should be like
loose and long okay yeah yeah yeah same
music okay interesting is any reason
why you believe it's not one and two but
it's three is there any reason i'm just
i'm just curious
um i think three is just more similar to
what i've seen people wear okay so what
you've seen
okay when it comes to the lower a b or c
why did you pick a but not b
or c i think c has knees showing i don't
know i don't think you're allowed to
show skin and i think this bee would
also have
like probably skin showing on the well i
mean
some legs yeah maybe it's a bit tight
yeah yeah i think
i think a would be okay thank you thank
you very much all right and for the
bottom you pick a instead of b or c any
specific reason
um probably just i get why what you see
more
okay with the lower half i feel like
it's just dependent on how
seriously you take the religion when it
comes to the bottom we said a b or c you
said a
why not b or c any specific reason
there's no reason i think
that's like to their belief as a muslim
woman yeah yeah we're not talking about
in general yeah
like yeah what's it like it's like
sort of like shining
dress in public in public in public yeah
i wouldn't say three i wouldn't say
supposed but i think that's
how they choose okay yeah yeah i agree
in in terms of their religion within
that paradigm
what they are talking about okay you
said three yeah yeah
i think i think yeah think about it
i don't know i think one but if they're
going for free i think three no no which
one is it they they should
so what what what say what they should
not what you are telling them to but
they believe
oh my god okay uh three
one or four one one or four yeah one or
four okay what about you
i don't know though so i would say three
or four three three or four
yeah i agree okay all right
i'm not sisters what's your name by the
way dana
sister dana megan sister megan and ellen
and ellen sister uh sister thank you for
your time
you didn't win but thanks for the effort
yeah yeah actually wait wait oh actually
hold on hold on a second
the answers were exactly what you picked
i'm joking
yeah yeah you guys won you know why you
know why because a minute
a minute ago i don't know i don't know
if you guys saw it i was listening to
the audio
because there was another winner but
they got it they they
just about won it but you came and you
got the exact right one so you got
number three
and a and then you got you said three
and four
and the correct answer is free or fork
but you said three and four
so so in a nutshell guys this apple
watch three uh yeah yeah
i don't i don't know how you guys are
gonna divide it you can wear a watch
each each day i don't wanna
cause i was just about to pick a winner
i was just about to pack up you just you
guys just came and i [ __ ] just give
it a shot
you guys got the there's two correct
answers
and you pick one for them yeah no no you
guys won
if you
nice okay thank you thank you very much
because you guys so for some people who
don't leave their house it is a tiring
day as you can see
you know but finally we're going out of
the house i think how do you think that
went i think it was
i think it was very interesting yeah
because i thought a lot of people don't
they wouldn't know the men's hijab but
those girls actually knew
so to me it was interesting it was
amazing and to know that the non-muslims
and one thing that
kept like one thing i picked up on was
like they were
making that judgment based on how what
they observed so even when they came and
said oh but i see you dressed like that
so
it must be that meaning if it wasn't
like that you wouldn't be dressing like
that
so it shows you that people judge i
wouldn't say judge but they give their
opinions based on what they see
and that that to me was very very
powerful yeah
definitely the best tower the most
effective tower is what
people see yeah the dawah of actions and
i think i think we definitely saw the
power of that today
exactly it was definitely very tiring
but i think it was you didn't do nothing
he is definitely retiring though it was
definitely just just standing yeah
the shafi should go home yeah okay
brother sisters okay hope you enjoyed
the video inshallah
if you haven't seen also you should see
the men's hijab which
is on zeeshan's channel yeah and
unsubscribe to ali as always
it's not worth it frankly he could have
done better but he didn't
so yeah guys hope you enjoyed the video
in charlotte check the men's hijab
experiment on zisan channel and if
you've watched this share with your
friends and family
you started with definitely i think we
should uh encourage other people to try
creative forms of dawah as well rather
than just that
whole kind of face to camp sort of thing
you need to get off that a little bit
yeah yeah you know promises hope you
enjoyed the video share like and
uh comment yes and unsubscribe and if
you want next one we're going to be
giving away iphone
se watch or iphone or an iphone x no
apple watch